que les prisonniers n'étaient pas des
sous-citoyens que les terroristes
n'étaient pas des monstres les paroles
Brest blessantes en premier lieu pour
les familles des victimes ce qui ont
beaucoup réagi hier sur les réseaux
sociaux et c'est les quatre Patrick
jardin perdu une victime du Bataclan qui
estime je cite que Gilles a tué sa fille
2e fois il sera avec nous dans un
instant Patrick et on va revoir
je sais que Gilles voilà c'est merci en
tout cas toi de bien vouloir accepter ce
cette démarche avec avec Patrick Norman
voilà qui t'a écrit qui voulait
absolument te rencontrer ce soir c'est
parti l'estomac est-ce que un terroriste
et un pédocrinel c'est un sous citoyen
toi tu dis NON je dis ce ne sont pas des
monstres mais c'est un vrai débat
[Applaudissements]
merci Patrick jardin pardon d'être avec
nous merci beaucoup Gilles Verdez a tué
ma fille une deuxième fois
Patrick vous avez perdu votre fille
Nathalie 31 ans lors de l'attentat du
Bataclan le 13 novembre 2015
contrairement à beaucoup de vie familles
de victimes Patrick jardin affirme sa
haine contre les terroristes vous avez
des mots extrêmement
dur voilà mais vous avez des mots
extrêmement dur vous avez même dit un
moment qu'il fallait tuer des enfants
des terroristes que j'avais vu passer je
dis que ceux qui étaient partis là-bas
en Syrie en Irak oui et voilà
aujourd'hui vous dites que vous avez été
très heurté par les propos de Gilly ben
oui parce que quand on me dit que ces
gens ne sont pas des monstres
moi j'ai regardé les vignissions de du
mot monstre dans la et le moment monstre
déjà ça dit que ce sont des gens qui
sont qui impriment la peur
à la fois par leur aspect physique et à
la fois parce qu'ils font donc pour moi
si vous n'avez pas peur de mourir avec
une kalachnikov
vous êtes un surhomme maintenant j'ai
deux choses à dire et j'aimerais
monsieur Verdez que vous m'attendiez pas
parce que moi je suis pas un fan des
plateaux et donc je connais les méthodes
un peu des journalistes qui sont faits
d'interrompre pour déstabiliser les gens
j'ai deux choses à vous dire
dans l'assistance dans le plateau il y a
des gens qui sont de confession juive et
Dieu merci en France on a le droit
d'encore pour l'instant parce qu'on
n'est pas encore complètement islamé on
a le droit d'avoir la
religion qu'on veut pas dire ça on peut
être voilà on peut on peut avoir toute
la religion qu'on veut on n'est pas
islamé en France tout le monde a sa
place voilà que ce soit pour l'instant
moi je suis pas inquiet bon bah moi oui
mais c'est pas là je ne peu importe
c'est pas là où je voulais en venir mais
est-ce que vous seriez dire à tous les
gens ici qui sont de confession juive
que les SS n'étaient pas des monstres
vous avez fini je voulais pas vous
inscrire c'est la première question j'en
aurai une seconde après moi ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que je suis du côté
des victimes d'accord je suis du côté
des victimes et je comprends
parfaitement votre douleur je serais
juste préciser il y a eu des victimes de
confession musulmane aussi
donc voilà donc voilà il faut surtout
aller il faut le préciser voilà et le
terrorisme frappe oui voilà en
Nouvelle-Zélande de conscience ou ce
sont des musulmans qui ont été reçus
donc le terrorisme aveugle voilà moi ma
problématique c'est est-ce que des êtres
humains qui commettent des actes abject
et monstrueux sont des monstres parce
que ces actes terroristes je les
condamne et je j'espère que ces
terroristes resteront j'allais dire
éternellement mais toujours en prison et
moi je dis que les qualifiés de monstres
c'est facile pour nous c'est un
échappatoire c'est les déshumaniser en
quelque sorte et c'est ne pas réfléchir
à pourquoi ils ont fait ça donc vous
avez monsieur toute ma compassion toute
ma sollicitude mais pour moi aucun être
humain ne d'être traité de monstres quoi
qu'il ait fait même si ces actes sont
barbares et monstrueux donc je vous le
dis avec émotion mais pour moi il y a
pas de monstre parmi les êtres humains
est-ce qu'on peut pas rejeter l'être
humain vous rogner la déficience la
définition même du Larousse du mot
monstre donc pour vous pour vous Hitler
c'était pas monstre bah ça veut rien
dire être à monstre extrêmement ça veut
dire que dans l'Antiquité
[Musique]
et alors on va je reviens à ma seconde
question si vous permettez
je sais que vous êtes marié récemment
avec Madame Fatou et claire c'est pas un
mot non mais exactement
la deuxième question
à ma seconde question vous êtes marié
récemment avec Madame Fatou imaginez que
cette dame j'ai rien contre elle j'ai
rien contre vous non plus aille boire à
la sortie de son travail un verre avec
une de ses amis et se fasse écouter par
décalagenikov de gens que vous appelez
des
êtres humains
comment vous réagiriez encore encore une
fois il y a c'est pas la même chose de
perdre sa femme que de perdre un enfant
moi j'ai perdu les deux je peux vous
dire c'est complètement différent
je serai
dévastéiez-vous les ces gens
évidemment vous seriez déjà
monstrueux
des actions monstrueux pour moi sont des
mots mais si vous voulez mais c'est pour
moi le terme monstre me s'applique pas à
l'espèce humaine en tant que tel je vous
le mais j'essaie de d'expliciter mon
propos vous voyez ce que je veux dire
oui mais après je Gilles j'essaye
d'expliquer parce que non je dis non
voilà Gilles bien entendu toutes les
personnes concites et toutes les actes
qu'on a cité bien sûr il trouve ça
monstrueux et qui reste éternellement en
prison monsieur et vous avez ma
compassion totale juste totale c'est le
terme monstre appliqué à un être humain
c'est trop facile c'est c'est le retirer
de l'espèce humaine ça nous empêche de
réfléchir
quand vous le mettez en prison
la réponse
humaine c'est quoi ton souci avec ça
parce que pour moi il y a pas d'êtres
humains qui ne soit pas humain produit
de la société ou produit de leur de leur
vous prenez vos roses donc ça reste de
la société en commettant des axes
humains des actinus
sociopathes et psychopathe ça veut dire
que tu te retires de la société tu ne
peux pas répondre à la barbarie par la
barbarie en disant ce sont des monstres
parce que la suite de ça c'est ce sont
des monstres donc on peut les éliminer
c'est ça la suite du débat et tout à
fait mais qui est tout à fait légitime
j'entends c'est-à-dire que si ce sont
des monstres on peut leur infliger la
peine de mort on peut éliminer les
monstres
non non mais ils vont le refaire alors
qu'est-ce que tu veux oh j'entends
parfaitement
contre la peine de mort et le débat
c'est ça je suis con c'est à lui de les
tuer non
mais attends
la justice a rendu ne dis pas que c'est
pas des mots sois gentils ils ont fait
de la barbarie regardez l'état de ce
monsieur mais oui toi tu dis c'est pas
les mots malade Marco c'est
essaye Marco non mais
c'est juste de dire ce sont des monstres
et ne pas être pour la peine de mort les
monstres les élimine les monstres les
élimine
dans les l'antiquités dans une tour non
les monstres les éliminer comme je suis
avec la définition de toi comme je suis
contre la peine de mort j'essaie d'aller
au bout de ma logique qui est ma logique
propre et aujourd'hui
et puis aujourd'hui
les gens sont à 55 ans je ne sais
parfaitement je ne sais parfaitement
mais moi je suis viscéralement contre
donc qualifier quelqu'un de monstre
c'est accordé nous accorder à nous le
droit de l'éliminer et j'entends
monsieur c'est ce que vous voulez moi ce
n'est pas ce que je veux il faut le
mettre en prison le sortir de la société
mais on ne peut pas tuer un autre homme
voilà ce que je dis futile futile futile
commis les plus horribles odieux à Jack
monstrueux des actes il y a une chose
que je vais te dire excuse-moi je me
permets de prendre la parole sur ça
alors remets-toi bien si il meurt ça
sert à rien il souffre pas là je peux te
dire que les énormément donc c'est pour
ça que la souffrance qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui de ne pas avoir de liberté
d'avoir des caméras dans la cellules qui
feront il y a une chose la mort c'est
quoi tu meurs tu oublies tout mais je
vais pas les plaindre aussi au contraire
je sais c'est pour ça que je suis avec
toi mais je pense qu'il souffre plus est
en prison toute leur vie et mourir en
prison qui soit mort parce qu'une fois
que tu es mort et ben tu es mort voilà
donc on est sur d'une chose je suis
d'accord avec toi oui il peut sauver il
peut s'évader de la prison ça c'est sûr
mais il y a une chose que je vais te
dire et je te suis moi je pense que
c'est lui le monstre parce que de pas
dire que eux ce sont des monstres
parce qu'il a pas vécu il sait pas ce
que c'est touchant mais en fait ce qui
veut expliquer
seul le pauvre pour lui ce que ce qui
explique Gilles c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
explique la plupart des des psychiatres
dont le docteur Daniel zaguri qui est un
éminent qui a psychanalysé pour pour les
décrits atroces absolument atroce et qui
dit que en fait ces êtres là sont commis
des êtres des des
abjectent mais que si on les retire de
la société alors on peut pas les juger
parce qu'à ce moment-là on dit ils ne
sont ils ne nous ressemblent pas ce ne
sont pas des hommes donc ils ne sont pas
atteignables par la justice puisque du
coup on les retire de l'humanité
j'ai suivi pendant 9 mois et demi le
procès bon c'était une mascarade
ça a été un procès qui a permis quand
même de juger des gens de la vie
générale monsieur je peux pas vous
laisser dire ça il y a des gens qui qui
se sont frusqués d'ailleurs moi j'ai
créé une une association qui s'appelle
ni pardon niouli où on va se charger
maintenant d'attaquer les vrais
responsables parce que évidemment les
djihadistes eux ils ont fait les
horribles choses qu'on connaît mais les
responsables les politiques eux ils s'en
sortent blanchis comme neige et moi je
peux pas accepter ça moi ma fille elle
est partie elle est décédée et je ne
peux pas accepter par exemple qu'un ex
ministre des Anciens Combattants parce
que quand il vous arrive ce genre de
choses vous faites partie des anciens
combattants ne me demandez pas pourquoi
j'en sais rien j'ai jamais combattu de
ma vie moi mais bon le gars me dit mais
monsieur jardin vous inquiétez pas vous
allez être indemniser je peux pas
accepter ça je peux pas accepter qu'un
président un ex président de la
République vienne à la barre et dit oui
on savait qu'elle est ce qui se passait
mais on n'a rien fait et le ministre de
l'Intérieur une semaine après a dit la
même chose et ça je peux pas accepter
alors Gilles parce que il y a beaucoup
de gens qui réagissent à tes propos ce
qu'a dit Valérie Benaim c'est c'est ce
que tu voulais dire oui c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de dire avant mais elle l'a
très bien dit aussi c'est que
on commet des actes monstrueux mais être
un monstre ça veut dire qu'on appartient
plus à l'espèce humaine voilà mais pour
moi ils appartiennent plus à l'espèce
humaine ces gens moi oui oui et
justement les procès permettent de
savoir pourquoi pour que ça ne se
reproduise plus de les juger de l'écran
si on a rien suivi je fais confiance à
la justice mais Cyril le sait c'est
peut-être ma faiblesse moi aussi je
faisais confiance à la justice mais vous
avez un président de la cour d'appel la
course spéciale qui est qui a pas fait à
mon niveau son boulot c'est à dire qu'on
avait convoqué des gens il a décidé on
ne sait pas pourquoi de ne pas les
entendre soi-disant qu'il était pris par
le temps et on s'est payé des heures et
des heures de à entendre des soi-disant
spécialistes belges qui nous ont dit
qu'il y avait confisqué les portables
des des djihadistes belges et qui ils
ont même pas étudié excusez-moi mais bon
c'est un scandale parce que vous me
permettez de vous poser une question oui
bien sûr
pour vous vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
moi donc les terroristes du Bataclan etc
les terroristes sont des monstres pour
vous oui absolument pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez soutenu le terroriste qui a
frappé à krisherche en Nouvelle-Zélande
et qui a fait 51 morts dans des mosquées
pourquoi vous l'avez j'attendais à votre
question ce n'est pas un monstre pour
vous absolument mais je vais vous dire
une chose et quoi c'est un monstre ou
pas oui oui c'est un monstre mais je
vais vous dire une chose l'avait soutenu
je l'ai soutenu pour la bonne raison
c'est que il faut pas faire aux autres
ce qu'on veut pas qu'on se fasse
soi-même c'est-à-dire que on s'est fait
nous mitrailler 131 personnes donc là il
y en a eu 49
d'accord
on comprend votre peine exactement
que c'était pas un mot non mais vous
dites qu'il avait le droit parce que ça
fait la même chose
parce que vous ne pouvez pas faire aux
autres ce qu'on veut pas s'asseoir vous
avez dit que vous auriez pu n'importe
quoi ce qu'il a fait vous avez dit ça
j'ai dit que voilà lorsque j'ai lorsque
j'ai découvert le corps de ma fille
j'avais qu'un seul objectif c'était
acheter une kalachnikov et faire la même
chose non je vous parle de cracheur
c'était à cette époque là que j'ai
déclaré ça d'accord bon et c'est vrai
mais bon vous savez ce qu'il a tué des
gens dans une société
ça ça c'est ce qu'on vous dit c'est ce
que vous ressentez quand vous découvrez
votre fille sur un lit d'hôpital enfin
c'est pas mais pas à la morgue donc ça
effectivement vous réagissez comme ça et
après vous réfléchissez parce que il me
reste un enfant qui est avec deux
petites filles c'est tout ce qui me
reste de ma famille et là vous dites il
est déjà privé de ça en moi il est privé
de sa sœur peut pas en plus c'est pas
des jardins tous les téléspectateurs
comprennent complètement votre peine
mais vous pouvez pas dire il y a eu que
49 morts et et c'est pas possible vous
pouvez pas dire ça là c'est un signal
déplorable c'est le pire c'est le pire
signal et ça c'est nous vous dites
bonjour Nous contre les musulmans c'est
ça oui
rien à voir avec les terroriste
exactement le monde
il y a énormément de musulmans qui sont
morts dans les attentats comme vous le
sachiez oui oui mais ça c'est le jardin
donc je vous dis et aujourd'hui la
communauté musulmane elle souffre de ce
genre de de phrases que vous dites là et
je peux vous dire que et souffrer
énormément et ça ça je vais vous dire je
peux pas vous laisser dire ça parce que
je me souviens que lorsque il y a eu les
attentats dans les prisons et comment
dans les banlieues on l'entendait les
gens applaudir
ils sont ils vivent des moments
extrêmement difficiles ils sont
extrêmement stigmatisés à cause de ce
genre de phrase j'ai demandé l'audience
moi à dalibou Baker qui était à l'époque
il a même pas voulu me recevoir non mais
j'aurais voulu discuter avec lui
monsieur monsieur jardin on comprend
votre peine et on on vachement on on on
peut pas dormir mais avec avec les
déclarations que vous faites il peut pas
vous recevoir aujourd'hui vous vous à
l'époque j'avais pas fait ce genre de
déclaration après vous êtes dans la vous
êtes dans la haine vous êtes vous êtes
dans la haine des musulmans vous êtes
dans une haine qui ne vous amènera nulle
part je vous dis j'ai vu que vous étiez
investi par le parti d'Éric Zemmour au
législatif dans la 4e circonscription du
Nord
c'est vous étiez déjà voilà dans vous
ayez vous suiviez ce
Éric Zemmour avant ou bien c'est oui je
suivais Éric Zemmour avant puisque j'ai
fait partie des premiers comment je veux
dire soutien d'Éric je soutenais avant
je connaissais très bien et intimement
je connais très bien aussi Marine Le Pen
mais à partir du moment où Marine Le Pen
a déclaré que l'Islam a été compatible
avec la République française donc vous
avez un énorme problème avec l'islam
c'est la théorie du groupe moi je vais
vous dire non le problème avec les
chiens avec le Coran lorsque dans le
Coran on lit il y a certaines sourates
où on appelle la tuer des couffars
excusez-moi moi je peux pas je peux pas
soutenir ça vous vous rendez pas compte
du mal que vous faites au musulman en
parlant comme ça et qui sont les jolis
quand il y a un attentat on est tous on
est on est tous pays il y a des
musulmans qui meurent et il y a des
musulmans qui se disent on va encore en
prendre plein la gueule parce que on va
encore stigmatiser
de vos paroles monsieur vous vous rendez
pas compte vous ne vous rendez jamais
je vous comprends vous pouvez haïr les
terroristes vous pouvez les haïr tout ce
que vous voulez
pas les musulmans
des musulmans comme ça